for many weeks now the Turks have been
resisting joining the american-led
international coalition to fight Islamic
state both in Syria and Iraq but now the
parliament has voted to join that
coalition and it reserves the right to
attack Islamic state not only inside
Syria but also inside Iraq and this is a
very dramatic development and why would
the Turks so suddenly change their
attitude well this is because there is a
very extensive and extremely porous
border between particularly as Syria and
Turkey that is itself a destabilizing
factor on top of that the Turks of
kundur enormous international pressure
to stop the flow of foreign fighters and
other volunteers and particularly of
smuggled oil across that border and
ultimately this becomes a matter of
self-defense it's of self-defense issue
because of course the Turks don't want
any more of that ideological violence
coming across their border into the
Turkish population they do know of
course that large number of Turks
themselves have volunteered to fight
inside the ranks of Islamic state so all
added together the time has come from
the perspective of the Turks to actually
step up and get involved
Turkey's contribution as the only Muslim
nation within the NATO alliance is not
just symbolic of course it has from
Turkey's point of view profound personal
national security issues but from NATO's
perspective it's vital because of course
the Turks themselves have a very
substantial army to have a very
efficient and modern Air Force and above
all they've got NATO bases on Turkish
soil notably at Incirlik and at Izmir
there already is a command and control
structure that's working alongside
Syrian rebel groups to coordinate their
efforts inside Syria so what they can be
expected to contribute and they
certainly will have already been asked
to contribute to the rebel campaign will
be training bases command and control
structures and above all coordination so
that these airstrikes that NATO are
committing are not being done without
any kind of liaison with rebels on the
ground
because the danger is if that happens it
is the Assad regime that had most to
gain from them if there's one thing the
Turks understand it is that threats and
dangers posed by their neighbors this
has always been something that they've
been deeply preoccupied by they have a
number of surveillance aircraft that
have been flying along the border areas
with Syria occasionally conducting
incursions into Syria they will have
access of course to all of NATO's aerial
surveillance that's been flown now for
many months over Syrian territory and of
course they have state-of-the-art
fighter bombers that can strike deep
inside Syria on top of that they've also
got surface-to-surface missiles which
bring a great deal more firepower and
arguably more accuracy to a campaign so
that they can actually use these to wipe
out very significant wide areas of
concentration of Islamic state forces so
all of that combined means that the
Turks have a great deal to contribute
and then at the back of both the minds
of people in the capital in both
countries would be whether or not the
Turks are prepared to send in ground
troops now they haven't ruled that out
which means that they may well be
expected to conduct ground incursion x'
to seal off a particular important
communications route and above all to
protect those vulnerable populations